jamie is with us
in huntsville alabama well good
afternoon jamie how can
ken and i help hi ken and ayo i
appreciate y'all taking
time to take my call sure the my
question um involves a new family
vehicle
so we are on steps four five and six
we are going to be needing to look at
look at moving into another
new to us family vehicle in a couple
months and so my question is how to
determine the amount of money
that is appropriate for us to spend on
another vehicle all right so talk me
through the process how much money do
you have saved
right now to go towards a car
so we have saved fifty thousand dollars
not for a car but just have
put that kind of money at five we have
other home items and other things that
we know
on down the road we're gonna spend money
on um but when i look at a family
vehicle
it kind of ranges from 17 000
to 27 000 and the fiscally
smart side of me i've always been very
frugal i'm like well let's look at
the lesser expenses but then if we do
the 27
000 then that'll give us a little bit
more accessories maybe a little bit more
longevity and more
comfort yeah
okay cool how much do you make a year
uh one household that's your household
income 120
correct all right cool so here here's
what i generally teach that your car's
value should not be worth more than 50
percent of your yearly income
okay so with that being said you could
look at a 60 000
car if you paid for it cash worth okay
um you're gonna buy a car that's three
to five years old nothing newer than
you know not a one-year-old not a
current model not a brand new one
and so for you saying you want to spend
27 000
on a vehicle um as long as that is not
coming out of your
emergency fund is not going to stop you
from investing into babysit number four
uh 27 thousand dollars but your income
is perfectly
fine all right uh so that's what i would
recommend
now let me also say this um i'm a card
guy ken's a car
guy um and there's nothing wrong with
buying cars for accessories but buy the
car that you
want uh because you're gonna be driving
this car for five
six years um so i wouldn't say
like hey go buy a ten thousand dollar
car i mean you're debt-free you have a
fully funded emergency fund
um i want you to enjoy baby steps four
five six and seven
within the proper means so buying a 27
000
car at your season of life and stage of
life
there's nothing wrong with that you see
anything wrong with that ken
i don't i i think this comes down to
priorities uh of the 50
000 is there a specific amount of that
50 that's earmarked towards the house
and other valuable things as well
well no i mean we everything is
completely functional in the home but
we're going to want to upgrade
and expand our kitchen at some point and
i i'm always just the one that wants to
spend the least amount of money
but then my husband's like you know what
we kind of want to have something that
we're going to be enjoying for
because when we run cars into the ground
which is why we're going to
get another one are you on the thousand
dollar model and he's looking at a
twenty seven thousand dollar model is
that what's going on
i think that's it oh su
yeah she's the same correct yeah i'm i'm
on the lower end and he's
he's on the higher end okay so here's
the deal um since there's nothing in
that 50
000 that's earmarked towards something
that's super high priority and
and you understand what i'm saying i
know eventually the kitchen that's going
to add some value to your home i think
it's a good expenditure
but the fact of the matter is a car
that's dependable
and comfortable within reason is a
higher priority purchase than expanding
or
renovating your kitchen so i think it's
a really simple decision
i would not i would not stew over this i
love that you've got a model that you've
picked out for 17.
uh your husband's got one that's picked
out for 27. i think you guys have worked
really really hard to be debt-free and
to be in this position
uh i'd probably do the 27 or you know
and that way
everybody's happy you got a nice car
you're proud of it and you dig in but i
think anywhere between the 17 and 27 i
think that's fine
uh you're certainly within the
percentage that ao teaches but
um this is a this is a make this a fun
conversation with the hubs
yeah uh don't don't stress out over your
version
versus his maybe you meet in the middle
uh but the last thing i would tell you
on a very practical note
i would do your homework on whatever the
27 000 model is
because if it is a type of car that is
known for
having a lot of mechanical issues i
would take that into account i don't
want to endorse any cars but i'm already
thinking about two or three brands that
if i spent 27 000 on it
that car is gonna run for a very long
time and be very
very dependable and i know others ao
that you can buy for 27
and within a year you're going to be
spending thousands of dollars on just
basic electrical stuff there are car
brands out there i'm going to dance
around this one let's do this
we'll just say that no no i don't want
to do that but i'm just saying
there are car brands out there that are
designed
and built to entertain you for two to
three years
because the people that are buying them
either are wealthy enough or
irresponsible enough depending on how
they do it yeah to where
once this thing starts to break down and
they're really nice looking cars and
they're well made except the electrical
can go
you can get onto google as i like to
tell my kids and see which brands these
are
and so people don't care though they're
going to drive for two or three years
and then they sell them they buy the
next model it's kind of like the newest
iphone yes
so pay attention to that because there
are some great cars out there
that a twenty seven thousand dollar
purchase is going to be a very
nice vehicle but also very low
maintenance because
of the durability so that would be the
only last thing i'd say there
uh let's make sure it's not a 27 27
000 shiny thing that cost you five to
ten over the next three to four years
you did you said something there ken
that i want america to hear
again do the research especially when
you're
paying cash yes i mean i'm in the
process now of trying to find a car
uh that i that i could trade in my aqua
for and and pay cash for it and i'm
spending a lot of time
because you know i want a nice car and
i'm okay how much is going to cost me a
maintenance i'm even calling around to
dealerships um let's say for example if
it was a
honda for an example i'm calling them
asking them questions
how much is this car going to cost me in
maintenance this is the year i'm looking
at
what are the most common issues that
come up around this mileage what should
i expect
in the future um because here's the
thing when you go and finance a car you
just sign it and just say oh whatever
but when you spend your hard earned
money uh
you need to spend time to do the in do
the research and then here's another
tip before you buy the car take it to
the dealership that produced the car and
have them do
a pre-sale inspection i love that advice
so
that way if you do spend 27 000 on the
car
that particular uh production company
that that car
company can tell you hey here's what's
going on with the car
or the car is in good conditions go buy
it so
there's nothing wrong with with
purchasing cars and i want to say this
before we go to break can i
every time i hear this i i just get i
get a little funny tell me if i'm wrong
okay tell me if i'm wrong right here
live on the show
when people get in baby steps four five
six and seven
they still act like they have to have
this cheap cheap cheap cheap cheap life
that they can't enjoy you know their
hard work
and and the money that they have you
know and i think sometimes they
overthink it like oh man i got i still
have to eat beans and rice rice and
beans
and i'm making thousand dollars a year
i'm out of debt i got a savings account
because i i just i no go get you a
mistake
i think you're absolutely right and
here's what's happening
so there's some it's the brain doing
what the brain is
supposed to do and there's some
neuroscience behind this what we focus
on
is what we act on and so when you've
been in a gazelle intense mode
you know for so long and you begin to
get in baby steps four five and six it's
really hard for your brain to kind of
change gears
because you've been focused on being
tight being disciplined for so
long and so you got to begin to do what
you're saying which is hey we've earned
this let's get a nice car
and we know what to do so it's about
changing your focus after you've gotten
through baby steps one through three
you can do it celebrate a little bit